[Music]
this is an image that haunts every
parent in America
the desperate gathering for news after
yet another school shooting this time it
was North Park Elementary in San
Bernardino the lines of children being
escorted to safety as police responded
to gunfire in a special-needs classroom
police say 53 year old Cedric Anderson
entered that classroom and without
saying a word opened fire with a
revolver his target they say was the
teacher his wife Karen Smith she was
killed as was eight year old Jonathan
Martinez he'd been standing behind his
teacher at the time another boy was
injured and is said to be in a stable
condition Anderson then took his own
life police say they don't know what
motivated him they've only been married
for a few months and they've been
separated for about the last month month
and a half roughly when this incident
took place but there's nobody that in
the investigation that's come forward to
say that they saw this coming or knew
this was potentially happened there were
more than a dozen students in the
classroom at the time of the shooting no
others were physically harmed certainly
I'm hate to have to take care of
something like this where we understand
that family's lives have been impacted
irretrievably today and our thoughts and
prayers go out to the family members but
for parents and children alike as so
many times in the past
it is a scarring experience so she heard
everything it was 16 months ago when San
Bernardino was the scene of a mass
shooting at a Christmas party that left
14 dead that was a terrorist attack this
was something different but no less
devastating for the victims Greg Milam
Sky News